all right david yes sir david uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally i'm from
tennessee
what's up in what city um well i was
born in a place called chapelle
but i grew up in dixon
which is about 20 30 minutes west of
nashville on
i-40 about three hours from memphis
uh
i'm adopted my
my real father was killed in the wall of
penitentiary which is actually where
they filmed the green mile at
before i was born my mom was a biker
[ __ ] straight up i know it sounds ugly
but that's what she was on how all
bikers were my father was
in an outlaw world
women of property and
if my old lady if i'm not my old lady is
also a year old lady okay they're just a
horse they're just property do what's
wrong with them they do what they're
told and that's at the end of that
but i was adopted by a man named
vernon a woman named loretta and oxford
and they're christians
actually vernon was a recording artist
for country music for rca he used to
record with on the same label as elvis
and i never really fit in like i said my
original family was a
ballerina i lost dope addicts you know
the whole night all of them
well they were going to take me for my
real mama but my real mama's
sister was my adopted mama's best friend
so they gave they adopted me
they have another son his name's mike
and we ain't talking ten years because
of my drug use and the way i've lived my
life
so
i just you know i just kind of did my
own thing i've been doing drugs since i
was 11 years old for the most part i've
had a few moments of sobriety
and uh
i just
kind of you know
i never really fit in so i started
traveling
hopping trains doing drugs
and uh i uh
i have just tried to make my way you
know in life and i've
traveled was fairly good with the
adopted family i would say that your
childhood was fairly good with the
adaptive family for the most part yes
like i wasn't mistreated in any way or
abused or anything like that
i just
but you know today you're living on skid
row um yes well i come out frequently in
my skid row usually i go with venice at
night or i'll stay like um
union stationary yeah
i tried i was taking skid row on and
slept on the streets in a very long time
it's just not a safe place to be
especially you know you stay in venice
venice or long beach or
anywhere that's not skid row yeah yeah i
don't blame you because especially with
one leg you're in a wheelchair for how's
that how'd that happen um well i shot
myself
i was going to do something i had no
business doing somebody earned me some
money and i was going to collect
and as i was going to put this i had a
salt off and i was gonna put it on my
pants leg you know to
go walk down the street and when i went
to go do that it went off
and i shot my leg
well i didn't i jumped with a hole
through my foot about that big around
like clean through my foot
and
they tried to save it so for three and a
half months or so i walked i was on a
walker
and i remember i used to tell joke you
know damn they just cut this thing off
and they didn't they didn't and they
were trying to save it
well
i called gangrene
and they had no choice then and then
what became a joke a man i wish they
just cut it off came to they're gonna
cut it off
and
i remember crying
crying like a little baby
because i didn't lose my leg for real
i didn't want to be that guy you know
well it cut my leg off it was i was so
tore about odd in the hospital the night
before surgery
like i really od almost died
and they cut my leg off and for the next
three four years i was angry
at everything and everyone
wouldn't really sit and angry at me
you don't know what did it
well
i
have learned how to adjust to my new
life without a leg it's hard
i actually had a leg and before i was
here i was in denver colorado i had a
service animal and a leg and they stole
both of them from me
in colorado so you saw your artificial
they still stole prosthetic leg and my
service animal
i um
i threw away my wife and her children
for drugs
um
and then until recently i have um
tried to
just bury all the feelings and anger and
stuff through drugs you know and i'm
starting to learn now the drugs ain't
helping me what drugs are you using um
fentanyl and where occasionally
methamphetamines of lsd on occasions
but fentanyl is actually what i've been
on for the last
month and a half now
i started out i thought i was doing a
good thing because i was in
denver
and i've been shooting injecting drugs
in my vein song it's kind of hard to
find a vein anymore
and i just don't like to be and i don't
want to be in these drugs you know i
started smoking what they call blues
which is the press pill it looks like a
oxygen i know it's got an oxycodone
like a roxy is what they call them but a
blue pill is pressed we're just saying
though
and
part of the reason left denver is other
than the temperature and the weather is
that
i was smoking 30 40 blues a day
and
do whatever i can to make that money you
know i mean like other than killing
people hurting people
just any other hustle i would do
and
i've never had something where i smoked
that much like i do i was going through
a week three four lives every week
you know just because that's all i would
do it took me five pills in the morning
to get well not even get high that was
just to get well
so i left
and brent came here
and i went from smoking those blues
she's now a straight carf in though
and i can't do hair when i have a good
there's a lady here that i've known a
very long time
and she's a hair one and
i could go to her right now and she give
me whatever i want
just because she's like my mom and
i don't see her because it does me no
good i don't want to waste her drugs and
i don't waste my time you know i mean
heroin just doesn't help
like at all because i'm on something so
that's so strong you need something
stronger yeah i gotta have something
stronger and
honestly i'm tired of it like i'm tired
of being a junkie that's all i've known
my whole life is drugs and like
i had an amazing wife that has three
children that uh
at one point loved me more than anything
in this world
well when i met my wife i was clean for
two years
and
we were together
eight six eight months when i relapsed
we got in a spot
over uh
i didn't tell you it was over she
couldn't either but that day i relapsed
and
it's been bad ever since
well
she thought this she got me out of
tennessee
and got me to where she was from america
texas where there's not really any
heroin which there's really not a lot of
within him real everybody's tweaker
that would be good well we moved there
she started talking to all her old
friends and she picked up the way she
wanted left off
and i didn't spend that equation
i was sleeping on the streets and giving
her money still she was living in a
hotel the nine percent time i was
thankful
well everything just got bad so
we was arguing all the time so i took
off
and i went to florida because there was
a man in florida kind of like
my dad you know i mean my road dad i'm
sorry my bro dead as we call them and i
was
there like two three months and i got
off the hard drugs i was smoking pot and
tripping i was eating mushrooms
well
my wife's
baby come home home and work things out
i was like if me coming home involves me
sleeping back on the streets and you
know seeing you whenever you feel you
have time for me
please don't do that to me i don't want
you back on duck well
it's like what i thought it was gonna
happen happen
so for five and a half six months i'm a
little 16 realm
family being paid very soon at this
point she's got her own house
and
one day she's on she's like i've been
seeing her the whole time
i'm sorry she she was honest with me she
told me i've been sleeping with somebody
else all the time and the kids love him
so i came here
i've tried to kill myself three times
since i've been here like with od and
stuff and
i decided i don't want to die anymore
so uh i'm just trying to get the nerve
up to get into a detox
and i don't know where i'm going to go
from there i don't want to go home
because there's just trouble back home
you know i ain't got no warranty but
i mean i'm well known and people and you
know i'm well known for making money and
stuff so people always trying to give me
a slang form and
i just don't be a part of that no more
like i don't think i'll ever question my
part
but i'm tired of tricks i'm tired and
messed i'm tired of the opiates i'm
tired
every morning i wake up and if i don't
get well it's a bad day you know
like i ain't scared of a whole lot in
this world like i ran up in the middle
and people were pulling guns on me i've
told them have you put guns in my head
and something pulled triggered
but i'm scared that's sick
scared of being jerk sick his hair was
awful
but it can't be as awful as the life
i've been living man like i don't stay
on skid row anymore
because skid row is for people i feel
good to give up on life these people out
here don't want nothing better than what
they got right now
and there's some good people out here
there really is
but
they've all got this mentality drugs are
more important you know and somebody
thinks your best friend give him the
opportunity to take everything you got
from behind you know saying like that
take everything like i knew there's one
guy he becomes he was friends
he'll be friends especially new kids you
know you can tell you you can walk
around here and look at somebody
and you can tell if they're hip to the
game and they're hip to what's going on
down here they just they really ain't no
business down here at all
and he'll get them all jacked up and
fear where they keep everything on their
body and the first time they're not out
snatch
they wake up they got nothing everybody
wear their clothes on their back
everything else take it from them
and
that's just that's you know i don't want
to be in a place like that anymore i'm
tired of being in places like that i can
remember when it was two years when i
was clean some of the happiest times of
my life man
i was smiling all the time i was healthy
you know like
i'm six foot four and you shouldn't be
able to sleep as much my bones you know
what i mean like and it's just
it's bad and like i was gonna go to san
francisco and i'm glad i didn't because
last time i left san francisco i was 90
pounds
like right now 30 to 34 is fall off of
me
i just shouldn't be that way you know
what i mean like i'm a big old boy
and i just i'm not happy anymore
do you feel like you are
the product of your parents the biker
and
yes striker girl i mean
more than the parents that raised you i
believed it yourself genetic
bad blood if you will i believe that
um i was passed down
my father's temporary and my father's
drug life my mom's drug life you know
and
drugs are really one of the most
important things in my life and i hate
that
but i have to have on me and i don't
know how to end i've got to learn
another way to function
and i've been doing several rehabs and
the best one i've ever been to is called
the hope center
and it's christian rehab
but it's not one of them
preach preach preach free treats you
know holier than now
everybody's in the program that works
here as a drug addict
which helps me a lot you know like
because i can't really learn nothing
because i ain't never done drugs you
can't tell me how self-driving you've
never been on drugs know how to offer
and uh so i'm looking into a program i'm
trying to find the program it's long
term
because 30 days ain't gonna cut the
budget you know what i mean they're
gonna work for me
so
i just i started praying a lot more and
i've asked god to give me opportunities
to
become better you know i mean
um
i've talked more to god and prayed more
to god and now than i have my whole
entire life
like last night they wanted you can come
get off
work and gentlemen get a little smart
with me
and i just said i said look dude
you need to go away
i suffer from multiple personality
disorder
and there's a personality inside me
named docs
and docs is dangerous dox is violent doc
doesn't care about prison doc doesn't
care about dying or taking somebody
else's life
i've never killed nobody i've come close
a few times
but
dox has no remorse
you or anybody else is just freaking um
what's what i'm looking for
i speed bump into where i'm going and
i'll run over it anyway i got you to get
there
and
you know there's no medication
for my disorder and they're finally
realizing that now that
throwing that much message down my
throat
is not going to help that other
personality
so we finally started getting to the
root
of where docs came from how he became
reality
it's starting to help a lot something
bad happened to me and doc became my
protector
so now if for instance so you you made
me feel like you were gonna hurt me or
take advantage of me
doctor's gonna
immediately come out of my hole and he's
going to put us out to it
and he's not going to stop till i feel
like the threat is no longer a real
threat to me anymore
um
i beat somebody one time so bad for
something they did
that they they during prison now
i beat them so bad that they wouldn't
turn themselves in and admitted the
whole thing
because they heard a child
you know and
i feel like pardon me that was the right
thing to do
but i could have went about another
debate
because he now wears a helmet
so i'm saying like he's now
happy man he was
and
yes in my heart
for what he did
i feel kind of that it was okay
but the other time
i feel like i shouldn't have did sextre
you know and
i just there's a lot it's it's kind of
how life is with me like there's a part
of me that's some of the [ __ ] i've done
the reasons were justifiable
but uh
i still ain't obeying the ladies ball of
the land you know i mean
like i wasn't obeying the rules
but
sometimes you know
justice has to be taken other aspects
too than
god you know than
the law
do you think i mean you had some of you
had good adopted parents yes
do you think there's anything that could
have saved you from being who you are
today you know the biological component
is probably
the biggest
yeah i think the father
you got through high school no i dropped
out
i dropped out in ninth grade
my i was so bad in school
the time i dropped out hell didn't
nobody cared i think the school was kind
of glad honestly
like i didn't care um i just wonder if
you were just destined to be who you are
today or something some close version of
that or or maybe you could have been
you know an upstanding citizen with uh
wow i would like to hope that you know
i'm this isn't my destiny
i would really love to hope that but
sometimes i feel like this is just what
was supposed to i am what i was supposed
to be
and sometimes it makes me really sad
especially now being one legging
like it's harder on the streets than it
was before
well especially because a lot of things
that happened to me now
like and i'm gonna stand up just you
could say like what i'm talking about
like
this is not all the way up and i'm a big
old boy yeah you're big you know so a
lot of stuff happens to me now that when
i was standing up before would not
happen
and that's hard to deal with you know
what i mean that's hard to swallow
that somebody can come up and talk
stupid to me
and i'm just oh
you know i have to now as before i'd be
like well who the [ __ ] are you talking
to man what's your problem you know you
can get in their face really easily yeah
i was like man i would snatch people up
quick i used to collect money for drug
dealers
like
i have
smacked guns out of people's hands
i took one dude put a gun in my head and
i wanted to put it down and start and i
said give me one raised why you blow
your [ __ ] head off right to say it
and you know and so today
i'm going to be humble i guess
but i hate it you see what i'm saying
like um and a lot of people know me out
here like oh girl i can't remember her
name but she come home she loves me she
gave me a bigger hug how are you doing
today you know are you okay
even some of the most ruthless drug
dealers out here will love me and they
will stop what they're doing to come
check on me
so that's nice you know
but like
i'm learning to do hustles that are
different now like i was a professional
bike thief
and i'm not talking like bmx [ __ ]
i'm talking like 20 30 000 bicycles
and i'm i'm used to honestly before i
lost my leg i'm used to having my drug
habit at one point in time was 1500 a
day
and i did that every day and yeah i
stole bikes but i lived comfortably
i would live on the streets because i
didn't have no overhead
you know what i mean
my drugs could be done for
drugs you know all my money went to
drugs and i didn't have to worry about
it
well now
sometimes i need a hotel room you know
like
sometimes because i quit doing this
you know like and now like i didn't
sleep but doing methamphetamines i'm one
of these kids out here screaming and
hollering and talking to demons and all
that [ __ ]
and i quit doing that because i'm not
going to pay to be that way
every time i do some math these days i
[ __ ] hate myself
i'm uncomfortable i feel like everything
i'm doing is wrong i feel like i'm
getting on everybody's nerves i'm
bothering everybody
and
so why would i pay to do that and she's
like you look so much better
you quit doing this thank god
you know
so and i'm really trying to deter my
penal use
like today these days
usually a 20 will last me i spend about
50 down fentanyl
but that's just me
it's not sharing that's not being
friends you know like i don't care it's
just me getting through a day
i don't see i've never been to the point
where i let myself nod out anyways
because that's a good way to get taken
your fans up here you know what i mean
if i'm
i do a bunch of drugs and i'm sitting on
the corner nodding that's the objectives
might get me
you know i just told my cell phone my
dog my outcome so it's happening since i
started doing the stint now
well that's why i just do enough now
to be able to um
not be sick
and get by in the day you know what i
mean
like yes i said everyone's love i can
get a hotel room you know i get a good
shower in me
and then yeah i'll get trashed because
i'm in the hotel room by myself
okay nobody robbed me again nobody gets
me
i mean and i can have fun
like i've learned a lot of tricks since
i've lost my leg to help me in life too
though like i watch disney channel yeah
i'm 40 years old and i love this disney
channel the reason is i used to be a
very very violent person very mean very
angry and very just violent
and
um as long as i watch a lot of disney
channel it kind of puts me in a
different mindset you know what i mean
like just like my favorite movie in this
whole entire world is aladdin
i love that movie i don't think they
could have picked a better actor than
will smith to be the genie i just did
the movie this makes me happy
you know
so
that's how i've started you know i'm
starting to learn ways to be different
in life
and i'm very random with my confidence
because i can't always keep track of
what i'm doing
you know it's i used to be so bad that a
week if you're having a conversation
and i just get them take off
and not even realize i'm doing it
and really my wife used to tell people
he's probably gonna get up in the middle
of conversation leave he doesn't mean he
doesn't buy just part of his av even all
that
um
i i can't really really ride
at all
um it's hard tell people that that's why
i don't do a lot of the benefits you can
get around here
because i'm afraid somebody's going to
make fun of me if i
you know
tell them i can't read it right i'm very
emotional these days
um
my dad's got dementia
and i don't talk to my dad because it's
hard
because my dad's always been my hero
and
i don't know how to say it it's like
he's lesser than he was
and i just know one of these days he's
not going to know who i am anymore
and that's going to kill me
you know man it's going to kill me in
here
because that's why he's
his approval has always been more than
me than anything in this world
this is your adopted dad yeah it's the
only dad i don't know the one i call dad
you know i mean like my real father was
dead before that's the story apparently
i was told anyways
is that my real father's diet and killed
the pen's injury
problem is not a real mother that i
haven't talked to in like almost a year
now i started talking to her and turned
18
but she's lying but [ __ ]
and you never know what the truth is
one time she tried to tell me that
vernon which is my adopted dad was
actually my real dad they cheated on my
mom with a real mom
to
make me and
like you said you want to be shake his
burning
if there was a
poster job for christianity it'd be him
like he's
real dear holyfield you know i mean he
lives in life and he walks to walk and
he talks to talk
you know
you know and for him to be the way he is
now it hurts my heart
to
understand why a man has done so much to
say in the name of god
if god's allowed him to have to go
through something like this i'm angry
with god
because
i can't help my dad i can't help him in
any way i can't help fix this situation
and i feel helpless about it
and i told tom two days ago and i said
daddy
i love you
i care about you and i don't talk to you
because
i gave him a reason
and he told me you understood and i can
hear the disappointment in his voice
but he said i get it sonny says i know
you're having a hard enough time it is
and then
having to deal with trying to deal with
me on top of it makes it bad
like
so
oh no man i just know that
everything the whole way the train hop
and all that stuff in my life i've done
for years is no longer working
like and i don't really know what to do
because everything i've done in my whole
life is falling apart
and it never was great to begin with you
know i mean but
what does a man do when everything he's
worked no longer works at all
you know so i'm trying to figure out
this new way of life
all right well david thank you so much
for sharing your story very interesting
all right thank you thank you
you